Jacob Riis log thanks very much indeed
for welcoming into your beautiful home
and sort of reminds me of checkers
I hope goodness well I've only been to
checkers once and that was when Ted
Heath was Prime Minister when we were
picking up my father who had a meeting
with him and as I was about three at the
time I didn't have very good I will
maybe you'll find out in a little bit
more detail as the years progressed I
read an a label in The Guardian actually
about you the other day saying hard
bricks it's socially a liberal Tory how
do you feel about that well if you go
into politics people will label you The
Times will be putting a splendid label
on you and the magazine's don't you
think this is the flotsam and jetsam oh
yeah public life and sometimes you think
people have a point in sometimes you
think they've missed something why did
you go into politics why did I get
politics I think that if you are you
know Peter who is the most distinguished
24-hour news would take over the
interview but we've better why did he go
into polish why they go into politics I
think if you've been fortunate in life
there is an element of public service
that is important and you don't to go
into public service if they can't
underneath they have the opening to go
into it which I found that I did but
also I find it extremely interesting the
ESU is in front of the country are very
important ones
and if I can make a contribution I feel
that I should know that many people wish
I didn't make contribution but some
people think that I can and I think it's
worth making you describe yourself as a
man of the people but you said it in
Latin I said vox populi vox bearing the
voice in people's voice with God and
I've always been very suspicious upon
Editions who pretend that they can be
everyman we are all individuals and we
all have our own concerns hopes fears
view of the world and we can have
empathy with other people's but we can't
be other people's and you certainly
can't be 2 3 4 10 million people's view
of the world so what you have to do is
set out your store as to what you
believe in what you think you represent
and see if that appeals to people and
see if you can have an understanding of
how what you believe in can help people
improve their lives and achieve what
they want to achieve in their life
what's politics about and I think
fundamentally conservative politics is
about helping people to lead the lives
they want to lead and taking obstacles
out of their way and to do that you need
to have empathy but you don't need to
pretend in a bogus way that you are
leading exactly the same life as
everybody else because actually we all
need different lives talk about empathy
we looked at your 13 record where are we
on hunting on fox hunting it's a
question of how best you keep the Fox
population under control which is as
high as it's ever been as far as I'm
aware and there are various measures of
doing that you can track your trapping
is very risky because you might trap on
other animals by mistake and shooting is
fine as long as you're a very good shot
but a wounded fox is in very
considerable pain so it's a question of
do you believe that the Fox population
should be kept down at all and if you
don't then it makes sense to be against
all these forms of control if you're not
against that then why do the pesky
little blighters but I wouldn't you know
I wouldn't ride a horse and and have
hands in front of them and I'm going
route them to this it's a question of
pest control you I'm afraid in the
position of willing the end but not
willing the means okay but I don't think
this is a political issue of our time no
no but I don't I don't think the law
will not change okay do you want to be
Prime Minister no I like being a member
of parliament
Northy sunset well plus what I don't
like is the right word I think as trees
are made us it is a matter of duty the
Prime Minister does it out of
serious-minded
duty and I think that's the right
approach to high government office but I
am very happy being a member of
parliament for North East homicide which
is essentially always been the summit of
my ambition and very pleased to support
treason as Prime Minister but if you go
into public service is what what you
were talking about previously and if
you're in a privileged background and
and the best way to then pass sort and
some of those skills is to go into
public service
surely the natural transition is to go
as high up that ladder as you can go not
necessarily there are other people who
are doing their jobs extremely well you
don't want change for changes sake well
for concern cabinet the answer that is
and I'm not going to be the trees mate
asked this question and then it gave her
the longest fit of the giggles I think
she's had the whole time she's been
Prime Minister so I don't any point in
wanting things that's simply not going
to happen she's not Prime Minister
anymore when they should be Prime
Minister phenomenon a new hallelujah all
men I'm not sure that she can unless
she's immortal or indeed mr. Cobb he
might have a different view but if she
wouldn't even when she isn't Prime
Minister anymore would you like to move
up into higher office I'm very happy
doing what I'm doing I love being in the
Parliament for North East Somerset
terrific and and who would want to
change will sacrifice up but if you
don't have a shot at it do you not think
you would have failed and you're in your
role as a politician no I think being a
member of parliament is a fulfilling of
all political ambition love living in
darkness straight I don't think that's
the thing to consider do you think they
would please me with big guns either
under the road well we used to have
thanks we were the American Embassy is
very near where we live in London but
now that's all gone so the good children
have seen the police with the large guns
and all of that
particular excitement no I did a proper
reason for wanting higher office what do
you think of trees me I'm a great
supporter person that I think she's a
very remarkable person she has amazing
qualities she is incredibly dutiful that
she beautiful
okay she's beautiful I don't think it
would be suitable to comment in that
direction she gets on with it and it
can't have been easy time since the
election and yet she puts her head down
and gets on with her work and I think
that's admirable she deals with
difficulties coming in from all sides
and copes with them her response to the
poisoning in Salisbury by the Russians
was an incredible act of statesmanship
getting so many countries to agree to
expel Russian diplomats so now I think
she is a formidable leader with great
abilities and that's why I'm supporting
her and supporting her and what she has
promised to do if the Prime Minister
betrays the customs union in your
opinion do you think there will be
enough people right into the 1922
committee in order to potentially have
her removed from office
I trust the Prime Minister she herself
question no I know it's not your
question but she has said on so many
occasions that she will takes after
customs union it was in the Conservative
Party manifesto that is the platform on
which this country is being governed
it's bizarre to think that she would
retreat from that promise so what if she
does well I don't think she's going to
and I actually understand why you're
asking me the question but as soon as I
start saying about that it indicates
that I think she may and I don't think
she will I think the Prime Minister is
going to stick to what she has promised
the British people do my pathetic calls
on that one hypothetical is always
fascinating but I don't want to in a
hypothetical sentence give a
hypothetical view that I hypothetically
were in supporting Prime Minister in
fact I do support but if she did not
hypothetically do would you be one of
the people that would write to the 1922
committee to say she's our Maria my
general view is that the Conservative
Party when it does that sort of thing
when it has
periodic effects causes self more
problems than solutions that the
Margaret Thatcher instance is the best
case in point and that left the party
damaged for 30 years so I would not want
people to be writing to Graham Brady
so Graham Brady I didn't know wise
because in channel 9 particularly I
didn't know be a wise course of action
who is the Labour Prime Minister that
you would most compare yourself to the
Labour Prime Minister's I most compare
myself to that's a report repeated the
question because you're getting time to
think about it are you
I knew time to time to think about it
because it's not a question I've ever
been asked well there we go
and it's a sort of process of
elimination I suppose I'm not very like
Ramsay MacDonald I suppose the one I
would most like to be like is Clement
Attlee I like stylistically his very
calm and considered approach I admire
the political skill of Howard Wilson but
you could view him as being a little bit
slippery some people do
Jim Callahan wasn't an enormous
successes Prime Minister Tony Blair I
think Tony Blair out of office is the
reason why one wouldn't want to be
compared to Tony Blair even more than
Tony Blair in office Mike I think his
post office excursions and trips around
the world - not the most savory regimes
on a profit-making basis has not
enhanced his reputation he's lighting
his pocket regimes that are in your
words not mine
but III think that some of his
associations are unfortunate considering
the high offices make sure one December
ticket well some of the countries has
been inviting but let's move on because
we have left out golden blonde where I
think they're coming to him the reverse
is true of Gordon Brown I think Gordon
Brown has behaved with enormous dignity
out of office
whereas in office I one doesn't know but
he never gave the impression of really
enjoying being in office so I think I
come down to Clement Attlee by process
of elimination
which of your principals are you most
prepared to compromise it's a really
interesting question because it gets to
the heart of politics that politics is
about recognizing at the only point in
being in it is because of principles
because of what you want to do but that
principles can run you into a brick wall
in the end so I think it's important to
have principles to set them out to be
clear to the electorate as to what they
are but to recognize that you cannot
take your principles endlessly to their
logical conclusion because you may end
up doing harm at the end of the process
when is abortion ever acceptable it is
never listed
what about when the mother's life is at
risk then it's not question of abortion
this is a lot of common
misunderstandings in sooth Catholic
Church the duty of the physician is to
preserve life and if the preserving of
the mother's life means that the child's
life cannot be preserved that is
something that may happen and that can
obviously happen if the gestation period
is is very low and the mother needs
emergency treatment and has never been
any issue with that it's one of those
things that people miss conceived for
teaching of the Catholic Church what
about when a mother again I'm choosing
my words carefully just took them and
what about when a mother has found
herself in a position where she didn't
want to be pregnant I mean that is
obviously ignoring the life of the new
baby that there is a child then to be
considered the mother's life it's not at
risk under those circumstances what
about the will of the mother and the
fact that she has found herself in a
position where she has not chosen to be
pregnant she has found herself in a
position where he/she is pregnant with
someone who she might not even know
you've got to think about the new life
as well as the older life there are two
lives that's the point did your wife
agree with you on even starts my wife
have you discussed it oh not you do tell
have um congratulate ADRA's Davidson on
my recent to happy news oh I meant to
write where I haven't yet done it I
think it's wonderful news it's absolute
joyous news I love the statement that
was reported that she said she couldn't
keep it secret because she was sick so I
just want to tell everybody which is
exactly what I felt when all my children
have been on their way and there's the
Peregrine you're not allowed to say and
district' orders and I've always found
that very hard and when Ruth Davidson
said that I thought I know exactly what
you mean I think it's a wonderful happy
news and the new life always is um
potentially goes a little against your
religious beliefs
new life is always good news potentially
goes a little so it doesn't no no yo yo
yo you're confusing things the church is
always in favor of new life there is a
new baby this is wonderful news and you
sold this is terrific there's no problem
with that
sit up you're going back to what
happened to create that new life that
doesn't matter
there is now a new life and that is of
overwhelming importance and a matter of
great joy and I read recently as I was
preparing for the interview that you
would have been described as a member
for the 18th century does that sting a
little bit I can't say more so that's a
no so is this all great fun I see no
harm in that the 18th century isn't
actually the best time of pond it's a
rather closed and corrupt pond at that
point with a lot of jobari and you know
pointment friends and neighbors to
enrich members of parliament that's the
glorious time the palm and two best
times the 17th through 19th century
should Trump be allowed to address both
houses of parliament oh look our
relationship with the United States is
our most important foreign relationship
and whoever the person is United States
is it is in our interest to truthfully
of the greatest respect in courtesy and
if that's what mr. Trump wants to do yes
of course it would be sensible to lay
out the reddest of red carpets for him
that he is a major I we have so many
interests in common so if so if he wants
to address both houses of parliament he
should be allowed to notice you should
know we want to make the Welcome as warm
as possible that our relationship with
the United States is a fond enough
importance to our national interest and
if you offend the American president
you don't just defend the president
individually you actually offend a lot
of Americans even if they don't like
that president because it's seen as an
offense to the country in the same way
that if people offend the Queen that
people of the United Kingdom take that
as an offense and it's different where
you're head of government and head of
state is is the same strong women in
your life well my wife very much
Nally my mother my agent a lot you
surround yourself by strong women with
strong women
I greatly admire strength in individuals
whether men or women I think strong
characters with backbone are interesting
to be around that's why it's such a
pleasure you're here if I may say so
laughs you'll get you nowhere
tell me about nany
oh no he's wonderful nany has been with
the family I think for 52 years 53 years
in September she brought me up as well
as my four siblings and is now looking
after my six children they've joined
weeks if she's not here at the weekends
and she was the most wonderful kind
generous person what would not anything
about some of the things that Donald
Trump has said about women um well she
probably didn't wash his mouth out with
carbonic sake but I didn't should
actually do it because she's too gentle
she never has been one for physical
punishment but I think that might be her
reaction some of these did you say it's
got your childhood to me oh I long to
childhood I was very lucky that I spent
a lot of it in summer search look like
my children I spent went to school in
London day school in Long who never
singsong said weekends and holidays and
so I had a really joyful childhood I
couldn't be luckier is it true that in
1981 you turned up at the annual general
meeting of gec yes tell me what happened
was long ago I think I thought the
dividends would be higher and I asked a
question saying that I faltered
evidential Bihar and and the dividend
wasn't made any harm have any effect did
you see that as a body blow at the
tongue no no I didn't think they would
respond immediately but my father was on
the board mother he was yes but I had
some shares in GC and I thought I had
the right to shareholding Lauren asked
for a bigger dividend President's Club
dinner um in your role outside
Parliament you may have attended events
like that how would you react
you had witnessed the sort of behavior
that had been listen it only frightful
stuff sure I know who implements like
that I know I just never have I've never
thought that so you so people that went
would have known what they were getting
themselves into I don't know what people
knew or not but I'm a terrible stuffed
shirt I've never thought how would you
know to stay away from that those sort
of ends I never got invited to square I
get invited to events with political
speakers you travel all over the country
don't you do associations somebody told
me the other day you would go to the
opening of an envelope I dress a lot of
conservative say sessions because the
backbone of Conservative Party is the
local party with people doing the hard
work stuffing the envelopes not just
opening them delivering the leaflets
knocking on the doors the other ones who
do the hard work to help you like me
elected and I think they deserve support
and thanks for what they do
that's an odd raffle and thanks for that
fundraising whoever success what do you
do if you won would you put it back and
let someone else win the prize depends
what the prize is I I won a box of The
Milk Tray the other week which I did
keeps I like milkshake my wife was a
pool she thought this was not giving it
back but the orange creams are the best
ones I think your favorite okay and what
about when you go to events like you did
at the University where those guys in
the masks were really rather unpleasant
I believe in freedom of speech and if
freedom of speech sometimes is against
me that's part of freedom of speech
you've got intimidated I was intimidated
watching it no no they weren't going to
hit me they just wanted to shock and
they didn't want to engage in any
discussion what scares you I never
learned to jump through the window I
suppose I might be lazy I've just come
back from Africa more likely though I do
that I'm not particularly highly strong
did I just hear you're rude lady touch
then
well that was momentarily invisible that
was asked what makes you laugh apart
from yourself
Oh lots of things the 18th century Drake
book it always sought someone fellating
century Jake burger and the dregs are so
terrible that they're funny I asked her
i heard that she said BBC hospitality
yes but they don't have an ear anymore
you didn't even get a cup of coffee when
you get the news not anymore
[Laughter]
how do you relax with the family
oh very easy I mean we you play ball
games you play Monopoly Trivial Pursuit
yeah we've been playing the Downton
Abbey board game with one of my son's
was given for his birthday I get bullied
into playing cookies by to happen to
know the songs my two-year-old wants to
go in the car and get up and down the
drive and would do that all day long
given the opportunity and hook the horn
so there are lots of things to do with
my children I'm very lucky I've got six
wonderful children and spending time
then is life's great joy quickfire round
to end here we go you ready I'm never
ready for these no help from the wings
okay
Chateaubriand and depends who's made it
if it's nannies cottage pie but if I
March I'd rather have a chef in real
sweatpants or slacks neither what
instead
proper trousers guacamole or mushy peas
Oh neither both disgusting little or
waitress because who's pay if I'm paying
baby littles cheaper Beatles or the
Rolling Stones
well the rating stones but purely
because of who breaks but PI upon a
wheel my father's piece in defense of
mechag with
was helps the most important piece my
father wrote Oh McGregor was imprisoned
for a line of drugs offense but I don't
over and my father wrote a piece about
this and which I was duly released it
was in late 1960s and because of that
association I would choose the railing
stone so this is not really comment on
their music so I'm not fit to comment
quarry or EastEnders Dallas if I have to
but husband dates are loans Dallas did
you guess who'd shot jr. before no I
don't need to do it yeah it was obvious
but then I'm a woman and I you know I
would you know hell hath no fury like a
woman scorned you know trust me on this
it was Sue Ellen sister wasn't it yes
it's car no no can't remember name all
right it's exciting the Edit yeah
sky news or arrival father any rivals to
Sky News welcome again and what's your
go-to karaoke song
I don't do karaoke do you know I'm known
you know I can't see I can't couldn't
carry a tune in a bucket but I would
still but what I've had got enough
champagne inside me I'll sing that's
life